this is what I believe ten years later
will be happening so everything I do for
that goal
your mission is important you are a
genius your ideas will work out be
consistent always worth thinking it had
you know five to ten years
you know why will this be a really
valuable business in five to ten years
and you know how's the competitive
landscape going to develop house
technology gonna develop how the world
can I develop rise and shine it's
expresso time what's up believe nation
it seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so let's
start your day off right together grab
your cup of coffee and sip on today's
message prepare for the future over to
you Jack Ma people like me I was born in
a very poor family I never got a great
education I filled all the examinations
for what reason I don't know but later I
realize I don't have money I don't have
technology I don't have a lot of good
backgrounds where we have a rich uncle
or something no they only that competed
with my people then young people is
let's compete for ten years later this
is what I believe ten years later will
be happening so everything I do for that
goal
I know ten years later this thing is
going to happen so prepare for that
because I know if I compete with him for
next Mouse no chance so this is how my
message it's up it's a challenge but
it's opportunity and it's the
opportunity for people like us this
world the most difficult of thing is to
convincing a successful people wait tell
him this is a great opportunity to
nananananana forget it right I've been
doing this for 30 years but for people
like us we're looking for opportunities
in order to survive so we will do
anything to be creative so this is the
message so the
it's opportunity for us it's a challenge
for those people who are 60 years old if
there's 60 years old and not
discrimination but it's it is tough for
them entrepreneurs generally don't have
a lot of patience and that's actually a
good thing we want things now we want to
hustle hard we want to see the results
of our labour paying off we want to see
you know change happening we have a big
vision we know it can work and we want
it to happen right now and that's that's
that's amazing I want you to hold on to
it and at the same time I want you to
have incredible patience because what
ends up happening is entrepreneurs often
quit too soon you had the right idea you
had the right vision you even had the
right execution certain it up but you
just quit you thought I was gonna happen
in three months where it's actually
gonna happen in three years for what
you're doing every single day you need
to be applying yourself and close off
every other opportunity for four years
and then you'll be successful
four years ago on my youtube channel I
had 7,000 ish subscribers four years ago
how did I get here with 1.2 million by
making videos every single day every
single day we haven't missed a day in
four years and in the past two or three
years has been three times a day
or at least two times a day just
grinding it out and in those little
micro moments in those micro videos it's
super impatience right it's like this
video has to deliver this video not has
to deliver this next one this one right
here has to deliver there's a lot of
impatience to make things happen and
it's knowing that this is gonna take me
years to get to where I want to go and
so many of you watching could have had
more talent than I did my first videos
were not very good I was not natural
natural in front of the camera it took a
lot of effort a lot of patience a lot of
doing a video over and over and over and
over and over and over again the entire
day making one video just being
of the camera that still sucked a lot of
you are starting from a place that's way
better than me I had zero editing skills
zero knowledge about lighting and
technique and all of that stuff I sucked
the head nut but I did it for four years
and here we are and I'm gonna do it
again
for those of you who are following my
journey who say well now I'm already big
I have 1.2 million subscribers you know
you're not a small youtuber anymore come
follow me on Instagram I've got 8,000
followers now 8,000 something I started
taking it seriously about a month ago at
6,000 followers we've grown I'm gonna do
the same thing I'm gonna put in work on
Instagram do three posts every single
day for four years and I'm gonna learn
the algorithm and learn the ins and outs
and fix my design every day there's new
changes that are coming out that I
wasn't doing the day before because I've
learned because I sucked and I still
suck em and I'm learning to get better
and for those of you who are already way
ahead of me for those of you who have
way more talent and design and just
natural skill at this stuff who may
already have 50,000 followers or 100,000
followers on Instagram uncommon and it's
not a race that like that I'm better
than you and that I'm gonna I'm gonna
get there and you won't it's just the
work like I will have the patience to do
three posts a day for four years because
I know what's gonna pay off my horizon
is today like the post that I made today
has to rock I have to be proud of it I
want to show Haden I want to show my
grandkids about the post that I'm making
right now today I want my grandkids to
see this single individual video right
now that I am posting that's the energy
and passion and fire and fuel that I try
to bring to every single piece of
content that I make I want it to matter
wanted to mean something to myself into
future generations that's that's my
intention
I can't always bring that out I don't
always execute but that's the intention
every single time and creating anything
that I do has to mean something has to
matter and then I'm gonna do that for
four years three times a day and that's
how we'll win and that's how you can win
I'm trying to show this to you not to
impress you but to impress upon you
that you probably already have more
Skills than I do and that you can do
this too you're just giving up too soon
I want to tell you that your mission is
important I want to tell you that your
idea is brilliant that you are a genius
that you can make this happen that you
don't need to sit on your couch and
watch somebody else make millions of
dollars off of your idea you're just not
putting in enough consistent work you
start and you stop and you start and you
stop and you start and you stop and it's
not consistent where if you just did the
thing every day for four years you will
win and so that's why it's so it's so
important that you love the process and
not just the result that you are doing
this because you love the actual work
not just hitting them million
subscribers or the million revenue or
whatever the thing is you're chasing
over the goal the goals are great to
give some extra motivation but the drive
comes from the work the meaning the
actual process I like making videos I
like now making an Instagram post right
you have to find the thing that you love
to do and then shut off the part of you
that is so impatient that you need
immediate results shut off the judgments
from your friends and your family who
say what are you doing you've been doing
this for six months and it hasn't worked
out yet yeah I know because I'm on a
four or five year plan I'm gonna keep
doing the same thing I'm gonna keep
getting better I'm gonna keep improving
and keep posting and keep creating gonna
keep pushing for four or five years and
then I will win and all of the success
comes at the last part all of the
learning and the momentum and the
traction starts now but it feels so
small it feels so intangible feel so
little but if you keep doing it you will
see massive growth in year three in year
four in year five and it'll be so
unstoppable because it'll be like this
huge avalanche it just keeps building
and building and building upon all the
work that you put in and so it's great
to have the impatience you're impatient
should be on a daily basis the
impatience should be driving you
consistently forward to make whatever
you do today make it awesome and you
need to have insane patience to know
that this is not gonna happen in three
months or six months or in a year to
have a longer horizon to think I will do
this for four or five years
then I will win if you take that
approach I guarantee you that you will
win and I'm so fighting for you to win I
so badly want to see you and I so know
that you can win and I'm so pumped I'm
so pumped I'm so pumped for four years
from now to see a handful of you say I
listen to that message I applied it and
I won so pump for four years from now
please please you please you be that
person be consistent be patient
your mission is important you are a
genius your ideas will work out
be consistent now I've got a special
bonus clip for you but before that I
want to know what is the hardest part of
being consistent for you what is the
most difficult thing that is preventing
you from having a consistency on a daily
basis I would love to know what it is I
would love to help you solve that I
would love for fellow members of belief
nation to give you some extra juice and
confidence and motivation to keep going
why are you not more consistent leave it
down the comments below I want to hear
from you thank you so much for watching
I believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
I think there definitely are things that
one can iterate on but the the core
thing is to have a great product and
then you can always improve and and
iterate on that in all sorts of ways and
I think you know I think even in in the
tech industry on what's striking is how
weak on a quantitative basis so many of
the successful companies were it was
just they had a great product and then
years later they were able to optimize
it in all sorts of all sorts of ways
whereas if you're just trying to
optimize and you don't have a great
product I think that that rarely works
um I think it's always worth asking you
know where you're gonna go with this
business um and so I think we're always
focused on very short time horizons
because you have to you know figure out
a way to get through the next month the
next quarter you know how do you get
some customers how do you how do you
track but it's it's always worth
thinking it had you know five to ten
years
you know why will this be a really
valuable business in five to ten years
and you know how's the competitive
landscape going to develop house
technology going to develop how's the
world going to develop these are hard
questions to answer but I think I think
I think the the great entrepreneurs that
I know always have some perspective on
it and it might be wrong but it's just
this is what's going to happen and then
it's sort of well reasoned and and so
you have a you have a plan and you know
it's when I was playing chess you know
in junior high school one of the early
lessons I learned was a bad plan it's
still always better than no plan at all
right and so you know have a plan you
can always change it but don't don't
just pretend that that you have no clue
about what's gonna happen and that
everything about the future is random if
you if you sort of say that everything's
random and out of your control
that's that's that's the way you set
yourself up for failure this thing is a
long-distance race this business is a
long-distance thing you want to be
relevant you want to be around you want
to be providing for your family 10 15 20
years from now you just said Jay Z's
about to be 44 he put out his first I
when he was 25 that's 20 years of
relevancy you know and like
so that's what it teaches me being
around all of these guys even uncle West
it's like been in this full of a while
you know what I mean he's been around
the game of basketball for a long time
it's its longevity it's not so when I
make decisions whether with single this
show or that show or this tour should I
get on this feature should I take this
money to do this song or should I make
my decisions more calculated about is
this something that's going to be ready
does this further my career or does this
you know I think about things in that in
that manner what does this do for me in
the long run raise your standard Apple
epic or its core value is that that
people passion not one drop of my
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
me I don't ever give up I'd have to be
dead or completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten Rose a success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual Clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details